last night the stars stepped out for the
2019 glitz and respect Awards in New
York we're posed received the champion
award for its contribution to LGBTQ
visibility the FX drama features the
largest recurring cast of LGBTQ actors
ever for a scripted television show
along with the largest cast of
transgender actors playing series
regulars in a statement Eliza Byard the
executive director of the educational
organization shares the cultural
significance of the show
writing hoes right Lee places
transgender and LGBTQ people of color at
the center of the story
providing younger generations with the
corrective compelling and utterly
enthralling narrative of both LGBTQ
history and the history of the nation
star Billy Porter opened up about the
importance of the organization on the
red carpet it's very important that the
adults in the building take care of the
children that's not happening that's not
happening in America that's not
happening in the world there is far too
much chaos and it's our children that
suffer and so this organization it's
specifically focused on the LGBTQ
community in the place that they're
supposed to build their lives which is
education I know what it felt like when
I was a kid and I didn't feel very safe
I've made a safe place for myself I
found my tribe you know I have that kind
of energy in my life but everybody's not
you know all LGBTQ children aren't
like that and we need to go help them
screenwriter Steven canals accepted the
honor on behalf of the entire cast and
crew and ended his speech with these
inspiring words if you take away
anything from this speech I hope it is
this that you are going to hear plenty
of knows in your lifetime and you will
have plenty of people attempting to dim
your light and you will have plenty of
people telling you to quiet your voice
and in those moments I want you to
reflect on this evening this room full
of people who accept and support and
affirm you and want you to bring your
most authentic self to the table so are
you excited for the return of posts who
are your favorite characters in the
series let me know in the comments below
and don't forget to subscribe to ET
Canada's YouTube page